can you believe i'm here i can wow can i
tell you something this is our 51 year
old parties
yeah you're having this is this is my
water that i keep back safe oh you do i
just you know i love this so no one
knows
it certainly doesn't rhyme with hounton
smelly
i was really hoping for a spit taken to
be honest
do you know i've ever done i think i've
done one a spit take yeah if there'd be
a comedian comedian school i had to
spend
you wait i got a c in spit take
it was uh it was not i've never done one
will you do one
a spit take yeah i'll try all right
let's go whatever will you show me how
to do it yeah i'll tell you that you say
you're saying it like you're grizzled
what are you talking about
now
i just want to say
if by some chance
this is not in the five minutes yeah it
ends up on the air who knows people are
gonna go repeat on himself
but like a sad amount not even a man's
year not a man's release
what do you say everything you're saying
is so shocking what if i only did spit
take spontaneous
comedians yeah yeah
yeah i was like garland best in the
business
old people look like raisins
are you kidding me
oh people look like what are you saying
i could just keep doing it you could i
would be happy i know yeah yeah
you're good to go with everything well
that's our thing jeff that's why we you
know the thing is i don't know if the
show's good yet yeah we don't know
no no no
you're great well the show
you are
you are doing what you're supposed to be
doing you are great at this
i love you
and you are he's perfect he is awesome
i am here by choice because truly i
would have waited till your next pickup
and there's more viewers yeah if i no no
no no no no no if i get
shut up
if i didn't know you
and i was like who watches what what
does this show yeah the show will find
its groove you know sure then it'll come
to you like everything will come to you
well your former roommate told me that
just be yourself
i told him to be yes yeah i want to be
actually a little like molly ringwald
you told conan was my roommate and when
he was do when he got the gig i said
just be like molly ringwald you're good
vaguely erotic
do you find molly you know she was in
the breakfast club i know exactly who
she is i referenced her
i thought maybe you sometimes say
celebrities as a cry for help like
please tell me who they are oh no no
yeah by the way also again the
compliment thing yeah you want me here
every week i'm here you son of a
someone falls out boom i love it i love
it so only last minute
i will i will do this show till the end
of time i'm thrilled to be here
you